despite Chris Farley's episode being a
welcome return for the Saturday Night
Live Legend audiences could tell that
the comedian was in a worsening
condition his voice throughout the
episode was noticeably horse after dress
rehearsal which wasn't helped by his
appearance as characters like Matt Foley
which required him to strain his vocal
cords even harder nor McDonald
criticized the decision to put Farley on
an exercise bike in the matte Foley
sketch and claimed he tried to stretch
out that episode's Weekend Update to
give him time to rest in future reruns
of the the episode the cold open and
monologue were cut out of respect for
Farley